ROLL.
ALAN.
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
DALLY.
DOT.
THAT ALSO.
YEAH JOHNNY.
GLAZER GONZALEZ.
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
WHY SO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LLEVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL.
MORNING.
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
FORTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
WHY CASKEY?
WINNER.
WILL.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS OF OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL IN IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE'LL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN SISTER BRIGID
MCCARTHY **** AND VICE PRESIDENT
MISSION INTEGRATION DIGNITY
HEALTH.
AFTER WHICH TIME PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WOULD BE LATE IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR --
AMBER.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
THE AUTHOR OF THIS MORNING'S
PRAYER IS ARCHBISHOP DESMOND
TUTU.
PLUS OUR BEAUTIFUL LAND OR LORD
BUT IT'S A WONDERFUL VARIETY OF
PEOPLE.
OF RACES CULTURES AND LANGUAGES.
MAY WE BE A NATION OF LAUGHTER
AND JOY.
OF JUSTICE AND RECONCILIATION.
OF PEACE AND UNITY OF COMPASSION.
CARING AND SHARING.
WE PRAY THIS PRAYER FOR A TRUE
PATRIOTISM.
IN THE POWERFUL NAME OF THE LORD
OUR GOD AMEN.
THIS PRESENT COLLEAGUES
RECOGNIZE IN THE WOMEN AND MEN
CURRENTLY SERVING OVERSEAS LET'S
RECITE THE PLEDGE READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR CENTER MCGUIRE ARE
YOU PREPARED [inaudible]
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE.
I THINK MANY OF YOU AGREE ONE OF
THE BEST PARTS OF THIS JOB IS
HAVING THE ABILITY TO BE TO WORK
WITH SUCH HIGH CALIBER PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE JOINED TODAY BY ONE OF
THOSE GREAT FOLKS IN I GOT TO
SAY SHE'S A TRUE CALIFORNIA HERE.
HER NAME IS JODY TRAVIS HERO.
TRAVIS ZERO HAS SPENT NEARLY
THREE DECADES WORKING TIRELESSLY
ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
GOLDEN STATE.
AND TODAY WE RECOGNISE TRAVIS
HERE FOR HER EXTRAORDINARY WORK
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
MANY OF US IN THIS CHAMBER WHO
REPRESENT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST GOT TO KNOW JODIE DURING
THE MASSIVE WILDLAND FIRES THAT
HAVE PLAGUED THIS STATE OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS.
I THAT THE ABSOLUTE HONORED TO
BE TO WORK WITH HER DURING SIX
GIANT.
AND DESTRUCTIVE FIRES WHICH ARE
DEVASTATING COMMUNITIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE TO SAY.
TRAVIS ZERO HAS DELIVERED ON
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM.
HERE'S THE FACT ABOUT JODIE.
DURING OUR DARKEST DAYS.
DURING OUR DARKEST DAYS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SHE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THE LIGHT.
MORNING NOON OR IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT.
SHE'S ALWAYS BEEN THERE INSURING
THAT FIRE FIRE FIRE FIGHTING
RESOURCES WERE ON THE ROAD. FOR
ORDERING UP THOUSANDS OF COTS
AND BLANKETS AND PILLOWS. TO
ENSURE THE TENS OF THOUSANDS WHO
HAD BEEN EVACUATED.
HAD COME.
FOR OR EVEN IN THE MIDST OF
CHAOS WHEN EVERYTHING WAS
BURNING AROUND US.
SHE WAS ABLE TO GET A CANCER
PATIENT THROUGH THE FIRE LINES
IN LAKE COUNTY.
FIRST CHEMO THERAPY APPOINTMENT.
NO JOB.
NO JOB IS TOO SMALL.
AND FOR JODY IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
PUTTING PEOPLE FIRST.
SHE SERVES SIXTEEN COUNTIES
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE CITIES.
AND SHE IS DELIVERED TIME AND
TIME AGAIN FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
NORTH COAST AND THE GREATER BAY
AREA DURING SOME OF AMERICA'S
LARGEST DISASTERS.
CANISTER -- HAS BEEN THE GO TO
THE ONE THAT WE COULD COUNT ON
WE OR DATA GRATITUDE IN WHILE WE
ARE ANGRY AND CUSSING ABOUT HER
LEAVING HER POST AT THE CAL --
YES.
WE ARE SO EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR ABOUT HER NEW ROLE AT THE
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT AUTHORITY
WERE SHOULD BE OVERSEEN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
MISS TRAVIS AIR WAS JOINED TODAY
YOU WERE WORKING ON HER BY HER
MOTHER HER MOM'S HUSBAND.
MEMBERS I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
JOIN US IN JOINTER BROTHER
MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR.
HONORING TRAVIS AIR FOR TYLER
SERVICE A CALLOW YES.
INDEED LET'S WISH HER THE BEST
OF LUCK IN HER NEW ENDEAVOR
PLACING GENTLENESS JODY TRAVIS
AIR
.
WOULD WELCOME MEMBERS IF Y'ALL
WOULD LIKE TO BE A COME TAKE AN
OFFICIAL PHOTOGRAPH WITH
MISCHIEVOUS HER OR HER FAMILY IN
A FANTASTIC TEAM FROM CALLAWAY
YES WE'RE HERE TODAY
.
I LIKE TO DRAW THE MEMBER'S
ATTENTION TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WE HOUSE AND DISTINGUISH
I GUESS THIS MORNING WE HAVE TWO
OF SENATOR DRAWS -- SISTERS HERE
WITH THEIR HUSBANDS SO LET ME
INTRODUCE TO YOU THE LARSON
BICHON ELLIE.
AND ALLISON MALICK SURE REEF.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED TO READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED TO READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY SP.
FIVE SIX EIGHT PURSUANT TO RULE
TWENTY AS SENATE RULES. TWENTY
NINE TEN PURSUANT TO RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
ITEM TWO THIRTY EIGHT A B..
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MEASURES REPORTED FROM POLICY
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION QUOTE DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REAR FOR TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL BEGIN THEIR
SECOND READING A MEMBERS ADOPTED
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE.
IN QUOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JULY EIGHTH THROUGH
THE ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL DIVIDE S. C. R. FORTY SIX
IN A C. R. THIRTY SEVEN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND PLACE THEM
ON A SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TWO FORTY FIVE AP TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU.
NOTED -- SENATOR ROBB.
THANK YOU A MISS PRESIDENT
ADDRESSED THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM TWO FIVE FOR A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU SIR.
CENTER HER TADO.
MISTER PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE BABY
THIRTEEN NINETEEN OFF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS THANK YOU NOTED
CENTER WINNER.
I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT -- AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM TO NINETY TWO
A. B. TWELVE NINETY GLORIA FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DULY NOTED THANK YOU.
NOW WE MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION
THE DAILY FILE.
THE SECRETARY WOULD CONDUCT
SECOND READING.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO THREE
WITHIN MOMENTS SEVEN THIRTY ONE
WITH THE MOMENTS NINE FIFTY FIVE
AT THE MOMENT SIX THIRTY EIGHT
WITH MEMBERS TWELVE FIFTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT SIXTEEN NINETY FOURTH
WOMEN'S. TO A WOMAN THE SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED TO
READ.
MOVING TO GOVERNORS APPOINTMENTS.
THAT APPROACH HIM ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT YES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
RECEIVE -- NOT UP THERE.
MANNA PRO TEM THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT JUST WAITING ON MY
QUEUE.
OUR FALL ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JODIE
EVANS TO THE ARTS COUNCIL.
THE MISSION OF THE ARTS COUNCIL
IS TO ADVANCE CALIFORNIA THROUGH
ARTS AND CREATIVITY.
MS EVANS IS A CO FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR AT CODE PINK AND AN
INDEPENDENT DOCUMENTARY
FILMMAKER.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINETEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYES
[inaudible]
ANY OTHER [inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS BY BATES
[inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL.
I CHAIN [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DOT.
BY THE ROUTE SO.
I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI.
GROVER [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON I TUNES.
NO LLEVA.
I AM ACQUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO.
NO ST.
NO PANTS BY FORTINO.
BY.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
HI WILL.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS CHAIN -- WILKE.
SIZE TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY MADAM PRO.
TEN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
FALL ITEM NUMBER SIXTY IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF HER AND KIM FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE ACUPUNCTURE
BOARD.
ROBIN NUMBER TO THE CALIFORNIA
VETERANS BOARD ALAN BARCELONA
AND ROBERT DOYLE TO THE
COMMISSION ON POLICE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
AND FRANK ALL TO ME OUR JUNIOR
TO THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD.
THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY
THIRD ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THOSE.
HE FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I HAD GUNS.
HI BATES.
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI COMING AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGED.
HI DELHI.
I DONT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
CAL JOIN [inaudible]
HI GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
I HURTS BERG.
I HILL I WAS SO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
I LIVE A TIME ACQUIRE
[inaudible]
I'M MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BUY MORE LUCK I'M A REAL.
I KNOW SOME.
I PAN HI FORTINO [inaudible]
HI ROSS [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
HI STONE.
BY HAMBURG [inaudible]
WHY KATHY?
I WINNER.
I WILL HI HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUTS IN
MEMBERS BURGESS.
THEY'RE ALSO.
THE RISE OF HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
PRICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
CENTER GAZER.
THANK YOU I MISS OUR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE WONDERFUL PARTS
OF OUR JOB BUT FOR ME I THINK
ONE OF THE NICEST PARTS OF THE
JOB IS OUR OUR ABILITY TO
HOSTING TURNS.
OUT FROM MY DISTRICT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY FROM OUR SCHOOLS.
AND EXPOSE THEM TO THE WORK THAT
WE DO HERE IN OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES AND IN THE SENATE.
AND I'M PLEASED TO HAVE UP HERE
IN THE GALLERY OME INSURANCE
FOR MY OFFICE THAT I COULDN'T
REACH THEM BRIEFLY.
A GEORGIA CARPENTER NATALIE
HABERSTROH.
KEVIN HOTTINGER WILL ALLIANCE
GABRIEL ON JENNA SHOT DANIEL
TALK OFF.
ZACHARY WEINER ADORO AND HOBBY
ERR -- VIA GOMEZ AND LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THE SENATE
THANK YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL
THINGS YOU DO FOR A CONCERT.
CENTER GLAZER STARTED AS AN
INTERN SO YOU'RE OFF TO A GREAT
START.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
AND WE'RE MOVING ALONG SARIS.
I JUST.
MR VILLAGES AND OR OR YES WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO DO IT LATER NO DO
PLEASE SEND AN IMPORTANT YOU
KNOW I JUST UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR HAVE AN EXCITING
ANNOUNCEMENT TO TO MAKE -- WE
ALL FOLLOWED THE WOMEN'S SOCCER
TEAM -- WIN GOLD AND MAKE US ALL
PROUD THEY ARE STARTING THEIR
VICTORY TOUR IN THE TWENTY FIFTH
STATE SENATE DISTRICT AT THE
ROSE BOWL ON AUGUST THIRD SO
YOU'RE ALL INVITED TO THE ROSE
BOWL ON AUGUST THIRD.
THAT YEAR ON TEAM USA THE FIRST
STOP ON THEIR VICTORY TOUR.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTENT TINA
[inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCK.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR PROCEED --
ON ON THAT LAST ANNOUNCEMENT I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT IT WAS --
RATHER EXCITING.
AND I'M VERY PROUD.
THAT THE NETHERLANDS DID MAKE IT
TO THE FINALS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
YES.
IT IS HARD TO KICK A SOCCER BALL
IN CLOGS SO IT'S A VERY
IMPRESSIVE EFFORT ON THEIR PART.
SEEING NONE WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ECHOING TWO
ELECTIONS DECLARING THERE'S THE
RUSTIC FACT MERELY [inaudible]
CENTER MCGUIRE.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS THE TWENTY SEVEN
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY IN
CONCURRENCE SB TWENTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT FUTURE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES IN CAN IT'S FOR THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WILL BE
REQUIRED TO FILE COPIES OF HIS
OR HER.
INCOME TAX RETURNS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY STATE IN
ORDER TO APPEAR IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY BALLOT.
IT'S B. TWENTY SEVEN IS
SUPPORTED BY THE SECRETARY STATE
OUTS PEDIA AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BUILT.
THANK YOU SENATOR. EIGHT ANY
DISCUSSION.
THING NOT ALL.
THEY'RE MORE LIKE.
THANKS FOR THE PRESIDENT I JUST
A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
CENTER MCGUIRE YOU WILLING TO
TAKE THE QUESTION.
I AM I DON'T HAVE CLOGS SO
MISTER PRESIDENT.
RECEIPT COULD MARTIN.
ANIMAL I'M JUST CURIOUS THIS
WILL PROBABLY LOOK LITIGATED AND
IT WILL BE.
ON THE GROUNDS OF WHETHER IT'S
CONSTITUTIONAL OR NOT AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS.
WHAT FUN WOULD PAY FOR THAT
EXPENSE?
AS FAR AS BEING DEFENDED JUST
LIKE ANY LAW -- THE CITY
CALIFORNIA WOULD DEFEND.
ANY LAW -- THAT WOULD BE
LITIGATED AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE CITY CALIFORNIA WILL BE
VICTORIOUS -- IN ANY POTENTIAL
LITIGATION THERE WOULD BE
ADVANCES THIS -- THIS LIVE
SIMPLY A BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR MORLOCK.
CENTER STONE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE THE ANGST TOWARDS --
THE EXISTING PRESENT A UNITED
STATES BUT THERE ARE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS OF ONE HAS TO
QUALIFIED TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
YET TO BE THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
YOU MUST BE -- NEED OF BORN A
RESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT SAY YOU MUST
TURN OVER YOUR FINANCIAL RECORDS --
TO THE THE GOVERNMENT TO THE IRS
FOR REVIEW -- WHAT IS BEING DONE
HERE TODAY IS PREEMPTED BY
FEDERAL LAW?
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE NOTHING
BUT A WASTE OF TAXPAYER MONEY.
OTHER PRESIDENTS NAME WILL BE ON
THE BALLOT -- IRRESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER YOU VOTE FOR THIS --
VOTED AGAINST IT. FOR REASONS
THAT I SUGGEST WE VOTE AGAINST
IT IS TO NOT WASTE FURTHER
TAXPAYER MONEY WE SHOULD HAVE
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL INSTEAD
FOCUSES EFFORTS.
ON USING THAT SCARCE MONEY TO
MAKE SURE WE TAKE WEAPONS OUT OF
THOSE FELONS THAT ARE STILL IN
POSSESSION OF THOSE WEAPONS
URGING A VOTE ON SB.
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU CENTER
STONE [inaudible]
SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW JUST THAT HIS THE PRESENT
UNITED STATES.
AND THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THAT WE
DIDN'T AGREE WITH.
BUT AND HE WAS STILL THE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES AND
DESERVE THE RESPECT OF THE
OFFICE.
THAT HE HELD.
I AGREE THAT TIME A LOT OF YOU
DON'T CARE FOR THE PRESENT
UNITED STATES BUT NONETHELESS HE
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
WE IN CALIFORNIA CALL HIM.
A A MOST OFTEN WE CALLED ON HIM.
DURING THE ORVILLE CRISIS AND HE
DELIVERED WE CALLED ON HIM
DURING THE PARADISE FIRES IN THE
CAMP.
AND HE DELIVERED AND WE CALLED
ON HIM JUST RECENTLY IN MY
DISTRICT WITH THE EARTH QUAKE
ISSUES AND HE DELIVERED HE IS
THE PRESIDENT I'D STATES INTO
CONTINUE TO CONSISTENTLY BE
HOSTILE -- FROM THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY TO THE PRESENT UNITED
STATES IS JUST NOT SOMETHING WE
CAN.
SHE DO WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO TRY
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DELIVER WHAT'S
BEST FOR CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
AND WHAT WE NEED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND TO CONTINUE TO POKE THE BEAR
I GUESS YOU WOULD SAY IS JUST --
IT'S NOT SOMETHING DESERVING OF
THIS HOUSE AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING DESERVING OF
GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE.
ADAM IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROHIBITED THEIR OUTLINES THAT
SAY JUST AS SENATOR STONE.
THIS IS SENATOR STONE JUST --
MENTIONED THEIR
CONSTITUTIONALITY ISSUES THAT --
YOU HAVE TO ROUTE THEIR CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU HAVE TO
BAD TO BE PRESENT IN THE UNITED
STATES IN HIS MET ALL THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE PEOPLE CHOSE HIM AND SO
I WOULD JUST ASK.
ASK AS A BODY TO JUST.
QUIT POKING THE BEAR AND JUST.
I GUESS IS THE BEST WAY TO SAY
IT AND TO ALLOW HIM TO BE THE
PRESENT UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE WHAT HE IS DOING IS
CREATING JOBS AND HE IS ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT -- WOULD WE IN
CALIFORNIA NEED THINGS HE DOES
DELIVER AND I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
GUYS JUST PLEASE STOP.
AND LET'S FOCUS ON THE THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH HERE 53% OF THE STATE SAID
SEN FOUR DOUBLE TO LIVE HERE
WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS.
WERE FORTY SECOND IN EDUCATION
SO LET'S FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA AND
TRY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER
PLACE FOR CITIZENS TO LIVE AND
THEM.
JUST APPRECIATE THE PRESIDENT
FOR WHAT HE DOES FOR US.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A CONVERSATION
BACK IN THE CHAMBER PLEASE TAKE
IT OFF THE FLOOR SENATOR MORALE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT ALSO -- COUPLE THINGS
THAT I JUST WANTED TO SHARE I I
I UNDERSTAND OR YOU GUYS COME
FROM.
BUT ALSO.
ON THOSE TAX RETURNS SOMETIMES
THERE'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
WOULD BE TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
I'M SURE SOME OF YOU GUYS HAVE
RENTAL PROPERTIES ON SO THAT
YOUR SCHEDULE IN A LIST AROUND --
PROPERTIES AND YOU WOULD
PROBABLY HATE FOR SOMEBODY TO GO
ON BUT YOUR RENTERS IF THEY'RE
AFTER YOU YOU KNOW SELF SO --
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT'S ROUGH
BUT HERE HERE'S WHAT I I BELIEVE
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
THEY'RE MCGUIRE YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE A QUESTION WOULD ENJOY IT
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM I LIKE THE PHRASE --
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF
FAVORITISM TOWARDS -- NINE AND
SO WITH THAT IN MIND IF YOU'RE
GONNA DO THIS.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO DO THIS
FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS BODY WHERE
WE HAVE TO HAVE OUR TAX RETURNS
BEFORE WE RUN.
ARE YOU WILLING TO DO THAT.
IT'S A PRESENT YOU MAY I ASK
ANSWER THAT IF YOU CARE.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GOOD SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
IT. FOR THE PAST FORTY YEARS
MEMBERS FOR THE PAST FORTY YEARS
[inaudible]
EVERY PRESIDENT.
EVERYONE OF THEM.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE.
HAVE PUT ASIDE THEIR OWN SELF
INTEREST IN PUT THE NATION'S
INTERESTS FIRST.
THERE'S ONLY ONE THERE'S ONLY
ONE PRESENT IS REFUSING TO
RELEASE.
HIS TAX RETURNS AND THAT'S
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT POKING THE
BEAR.
WE'RE DOING WHAT'S RIGHT.
WE'RE DOING WHAT 60% OF
AMERICANS WANT.
AMERICANS WANT THEIR LEADER TO
BE ABLE TO RELEASE.
HIS OR HER TAX RETURNS.
AND WHAT I WILL SAY THAT WE HAVE
AMENDED THIS BILL WE AMENDED THE
BILL TO BE ABLE TO INCLUDE THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
BY THE WAY GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
HAS LED THE WAY HE DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO HIDE HE RELEASED.
EVERY TAX FOR MRS RETURN.
SO DID RONALD REAGAN.
GEORGE W. BUSH.
GEORGE H. W. BUSH [inaudible]
JIMMY CARTER [inaudible]
BARACK OBAMA.
WE CURRENTLY DISCLOSE MORE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION.
THROUGH OUR FTP SEEING CONFLICT
OF INTEREST REPORTS IN THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WE IN
THIS DISTINGUISHED BODY.
SO IT IS CITY COUNCILMAN.
SO THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
SANITATION DISTRICT MEMBERS
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT -- ONLY ONES IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LIES.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THIS.
INCOME TAX RETURNS ARE CRITICAL.
WE TOOK AN AMENDMENT.
IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT CLEARLY
SHOWS WHAT WILL BE REJECTED AND
WHAT WILL NOT. TO BE ABLE.
TO INSURE PRIVACY IS WITH --
WITH HELD UP PRIVATE INFORMATION
IS WITHHELD.
IN REJECTED ON THE INTERNET AND
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO GOOGLE.
GEORGE H. W. BUSH GEORGE W. BUSH
AROUND REAGAN TAX RETURNS THOSE
HAVE ALSO BEEN REDACTED.
IN WE ARE INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR
OF CALIFORNIA I'VE HEARD FROM
MANY FOLKS IN ON THIS FLOOR THEY
THEY LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS COVERED WE ARE NOW.
HAVING THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS BILL.
BIGGEST TOPIC WIRE YEAH I. EAT
THEM AROUND MY QUESTION WAS.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO MAKE A
BILL OR ADD THIS ON IT EVERY ONE
OF US IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
STATE SENATE.
REVEAL OUR TAX RETURNS BEFORE WE
FILE THAT WAS MY QUESTION THIS
IS THE BILL THAT IS IN FRONT OF
US TODAY AND I ENCOURAGE ANY
SENATOR WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE THEIR OWN PIECE
OF LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO DO
SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR MORALE
CENTER WEINER.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I I
I I WANT.
TO REITERATE I I UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERYTHING IN THE UNIVERSE SEEMS
TO ROUTE REVOLVE AROUND DONALD
TRUMP THESE DAYS THE NEWS CYCLE
EVERYTHING ELSE AND AND THAT IS
WHAT IT IS -- BY THIS BILL DOES
NOT SAY THE WORDS DONALD TRUMP --
THIS BILL APPLIES TO EVERYONE
AND SO BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY KAMEL HARRISON ELIZABETH
WARREN AND BERNIE SANDERS AND
JOE BIDEN AND EVERYONE ELSE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DISCLOSE
THEIR FORMS AND IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE GOVERNOR AND
WHOEVER ELSE IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR WE'LL HAVE TO DISCLOSE
THEIR TAX RETURNS THIS APPLIES
TO EVERYONE -- AND SO I THINK
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THIS
PRESIDENT AS MUCH AS WE ALL DO --
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE LONG RUN
AND THE REALITY IS EVERYONE
ASSUMES FOR DECADES THAT IT WAS
MANDATORY THAT YOU DISCLOSE YOUR
TAX RETURNS BECAUSE EVERY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AT THE
PEOPLE JUST ASSUME.
AND THIS PRESIDENT HAPPENS TO
REVEAL THAT -- AND MAKE CLEAR TO
EVERYONE THAT IT ACTUALLY ISN'T
REQUIRED.
AND PEOPLE WERE HORRIFIED NOT
JUST BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP BUT
BECAUSE EVERYONE.
THINKS THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES WE
SHOULD HAVE TRANSPARENCY -- YES
THERE ARE OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THE GOVERNOR IS
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL BUT LET'S
BE VERY VERY CLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS A UNIQUE POSITION IN
THE WORLD IT IS THE MOST
POWERFUL POSITION IN THE WORLD.
IT IS A POSITION WHERE YOU CAN
INFLUENCE THE FUTURE OF THE
ENTIRE WORLD AND SO IT IS A
UNIQUE SITUATION AND THIS IS THE
LEAST THAT WE CAN DO. TO KNOW
WHO IT IS WERE VOTING FOR I
ASKED FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER SENATOR
ALAN.
WELL I'VE MEMBERS I ADJUSTED
ANSWER THE QUESTION FROM THE THE
CENTER FROM IRAN TO COOK AMONG I
DO THINK THAT THE BEST ANSWER
THAT WAS MADE BY.
OUR FRIEND FROM HEALDSBURG IS
THAT -- THAT WE ALL DO FILL OUT
VERY ROBUST.
FORMS TO RUN FOR THIS OFFICE
THAT REALLY DO FOCUS IN ON
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
I WAS PART OF WHY I THOUGHT THAT
WE SHOULD PROVIDE AN OPTION --
AS PART OF THIS BILL FOR
PRESENCE OF CANDIDATES TO DO THE
SAME SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVELY
SIMILAR WHAT TO THE FORM --
SEVEN HUNDRED BUT I AM HAPPY --
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL -- AS IT IS
I I DO THINK THERE ARE KIND OF
CORE CONFLICT OF INTEREST IN
DISCLOSURE PRINCIPLES THAT ARE
AT THE HEART OF THE FOUR SEVEN
HUNDRED THAT ARE ALSO AT THE
HEART OF WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO DO.
SO THAT VOTERS CAN HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS THAT EXIST WHEN PEOPLE
ARE RUNNING.
FOR POSITIONS OF PUBLIC TRUST I
BELIEVE THAT I'VE I'VE GOT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
THEY REQUIRE YOU WILLING TO TAKE
A QUESTION WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
FROM THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA THE CENTER DO YOU WANT TO
USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ANNOUNCE
YOUR BID FOR THE PRESIDENCY IN.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT I'M ALL IN
FOR HARRIS OKAY ALL RIGHT --
TWENTY EIGHT IN THE AREA. TWENTY
EIGHT GOOD STUFF.
ALL RIGHT DAVE THANK YOU SAID
AROUND A CENTER IN YELTSIN.
THIS PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE.
PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
PROCEED.
GRANTED GOVERNOR BROWN AND I
OVER THE DECADES OF AGREED ON A
LOT OF THINGS AND DISAGREED ON
SOME.
HIS VETO MESSAGE OF THIS SAME
MEASURE A YEAR AGO.
I THINK IS INSTRUCTIVE
[inaudible]
AN APPROPRIATE.
HE SAID WELL I RECOGNIZE THE
POLITICAL EFFECTIVENESS EVEN THE
MERITS OF GETTING PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS I WORRY
ABOUT THE POLITICAL PERILS OF
INDIVIDUAL STATES.
SEEKING TO REGULATE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS IN THIS MANNER.
FIRST IT MAY NOT BE
CONSTITUTIONAL.
SECOND IT SEEMS A SLIPPERY SLOPE
PRESIDENT.
THE DAY WOULD REQUIRE TAX
RETURNS BUT WHAT WOULD BE NEXT.
FIVE YEARS OF HEALTH RETURNS
RECORDS CERTIFIED BIRTH
CERTIFICATE HIGH SCHOOL REPORT
CARDS.
AND WHILE THESE REQUIREMENTS
VARY DEPENDING ON WHICH
POLITICAL PARTY.
IS IN POWER.
DEMOCRATS MIGHT TO THINK ABOUT
THE ATTACKS ON PRESIDENT OBAMA'S.
ORIGIN OF BIRTH.
THEY DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS
PLEASANT.
THEY MADE A FUSS OVER.
MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE.
AND I THINK HERE WE SHOULD MAKE
A FUSS OF THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN.
CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT WILL
SINCE WE'RE GONNA HAVE SO MUCH
DISCUSSION ON CONCURRENCE I
THINK WE ALREADY LITIGATED THIS
BUT I KIND OF FEEL LIKE I HAVE
TO JUMP INTO -- I DO THINK THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A HORRIBLE HUMAN
BEING BUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT THAT
THIS IS ABOUT PROTOCOL AND THIS
IS ABOUT WHAT EVERY OTHER --
PRESIDENT HAS DONE AND WHY DOES
HE THINK THAT HE IS BETTER THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT AND HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO DOTHIS.
SO I AM PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
WITH YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE AND I
THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND IT REALLY SHOULDN'T
BE THAT DIFFICULT AND I'M HAPPY
TO HAVE ANYONE LOOK AT THE
LABELS TAX RETURNS.
THE REALLY QUITE BORING THEY'LL
PROBABLY PUT YOU TO SLEEP BUT
I'M HAPPY TO PUT THEM OUT THERE
IF NEED BE THANK YOU I URGE AND
I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR LAY THE CENTER
STERN SURE I'LL.
I'LL ADD T A WONKY YOUR FINAL
COMMENT -- BEFORE THE GOOD
CENTER FROM THE NORTH COAST --
CLOSE IS HERE A STORE V. BROWN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR REASONABLE
CONDITIONS -- CAN GO FURTHER --
BUT NOT SAID SUBSTANTIVE
CONDITIONS ON WHO CAN RUN SO I
THINK UNDERLYING THE ENERGY OF
THE CONVERSATION DAYS WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS A SUBSTANTIVE
CONDITION.
OR NOT ON THE PRESIDENT
QUALIFYING -- TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
OFFICE OUR OTHER CANDIDATES.
AND THE QUESTION OF SUBMITTING-ONE FORM -- THAT IS A A GENERAL
FORM IN TAX LAW THAT APPLIES
UNIVERSALLY -- IS ACTUALLY NOT A
SUBSTANTIVE REQUIREMENT BUT
RATHER PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENT
THAT WE FEEL QUITE STRONGLY --
UNDER A STARRY DECISIS IF IT IS
STILL UP HELD BY THE SUPREME
COURT AND THE WEIGHT OF
PRECEDENT SHOULD RELY HEAVILY IN
FAVOR THIS MEASURE -- WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN CENTER
DRAWS SO [inaudible]
YES -- I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
KNOW.
WHAT ARE THE SOURCES?
OF INCOME FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS.
THAT A PRESIDENT DECIDES.
WHO KNOWS MAY COME BACK TO THE
ISSUE OF HOW HE OR SHE IS MAKING
MONEY?
WHAT KIND OF INCOME THEY'RE
BRINGING?
YOU KNOW IS THERE A CONNECTION
BETWEEN.
THE PRIVATE PRISON INDUSTRY AND
DETENTION CENTERS AND A SOURCE
OF INCOME FOR THE PRESIDENT --
PHARMACEUTICAL THE PROFITS MADE
BY PROMISE CIRCLES CAN THAT BE
TRACED BACK TO THE SOURCE OF
INCOME.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO KNOW.
WHERE THE INCOME IS OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA SO THAT WE COULD KNOW
IS THERE A CONNECTION TO THE
KINDS OF DECISIONS AND POLICIES
THAT HE OR SHE PUT FORWARD THANK
YOU?
THANK YOU SENATOR -- SO.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE SAT.
WHY ARE YOU MAY CLOSE?
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES INTO OUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES FOR A ROBUST DEBATE.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WE COULD
DO THIS MORE OFTEN.
RATHER THAN YELLING AT EACH
OTHER WE ARE ABLE TO TALK WITH
EACH OTHER.
AND I GOTTA SAY IT REALLY PROUD
OF THIS DISTINGUISHED BODY THAT
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT AND HAVE
THESE TYPE OF CONVERSATIONS
WHETHER IT'S HERE ON THE FLOOR
IN COMMITTEE OR IN OUR OFFICES.
I'D LIKE TO FINISH WITH A COUPLE
OF ITEMS IN A QUESTION.
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT GOVERNOR
BROWN.
GOVERNOR BROWN WILL GO DOWN IN
HISTORY AS ONE OF THE GREATEST
GOVERNORS OF OUR TIME.
AND HE WASN'T A FAN OF RELEASING
HIS OWN TAX RETURNS.
SO I WILL SHARE WITH YOU WE HAVE
HAD SOME OF THE BRIGHTEST MINDS
IN CONSTITUTIONAL LAW LOOK AT
THIS BILL.
FORMER ETHICS ATTORNEYS.
FOR PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS BOTH
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL WITHHOLD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TEST.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL TESTS.
S. B. TWICE AS VALID OUR AXES
REQUIREMENTS OF RELEASING TAX
RETURNS IS LIKE ANY OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENT.
THAT STATES HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE FOR
EXAMPLE [inaudible]
SIGNATURE GATHERING [inaudible]
FILING FEES.
SUBSTANTIAL DEADLINES FOR THE
SECRETARY STATE.
GUIDELINES THAT HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY.
EVERYONE CAN YOU CHEAT.
IN THIS BILL IF YOU DO NOT PAY
YOUR TAXES OR YOU DON'T MAKE
ENOUGH TO PAY TAXES.
YOU CAN STILL GET ON THE BALLOT.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
DECLINE TO STATE SEN
LIBERTARIANS.
IF YOU PAY YOUR TAXES YOU HAVE
TO RELEASE YOUR TAX RETURNS IT'S
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY IN THE
CONSTITUTION IS VERY CLEAR.
EIGHT STATES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO IMPOSE BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS.
ON TO THE PRIMARY BALLOT AND
WE'VE ALSO CHECK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IS WELL.
AND THAT IS WHY WERE FOCUSED ON
THE PRIMARY BALLOT.
WHERE WE WILL RUN INTO
CHALLENGES IF WE DO WHAT GEORGIA
TRIED AND THAT IS PUTTING TERM
LIMITS ON TO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ARE MEMBERS OF THE US SENATE OR
TALKING ABOUT RESIDENCE
REQUIREMENTS?
OR TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL PAY FOR
FEDERAL ELECTION OFFICIALS THIS
IS SIMPLY A BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS [inaudible]
FINALLY MEMBERS.
ALL IN WITH A QUESTION
[inaudible]
WHAT?
DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HAVE TO HIDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU SAM REQUIRED MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
HI BATES.
NOBEL.
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
NO VALLEY [inaudible]
NO DOG.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GOT JOHNNY.
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL I WAS SO.
I TADO.
BY JACKSON.
ITUNES [inaudible]
NO LABOR.
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NELSON [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I FORTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NO AMBERG.
HI WHAT CASKEY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
NOW. 539- KNOWS TEN THESE SIMPLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR UMBERG.
CENTER I'M BURGER YOU PREPARED.
BY LIGHT OF SIXTY EIGHT I'M
READY.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FIVE OH FIVE A SENATOR
UMBERG AND ACTUALLY INTO
ELECTIONS DECLARING THEIR THREAT
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
ENTER AMBERG A MISS PRESENT
MEMBERS -- THIS IS JUST
CONCURRENCE IN A BILL PASSED BY
THIS HOUSE -- CONCERNING.
HOW A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
ACCESS IS THE BALLOT CURRENTLY
IT'S A SUBJECTIVE STANDARD THE
SECTOR STATE CAN DECIDE?
WHO HE -- WISHES THEY HAVE ON
THE BALLOT THIS ADD SOME
CRITERIA THE ASSEMBLY --
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY REDUCE THAT
CRITERIA TO ONE OF A LIST.
I URGE NO VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
I BATES [inaudible]
BILL.
BY BURGESS BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
I DELI [inaudible]
I TAUGHT.
I THE RISE OF I GUESS JOHNNY
[inaudible]
I GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
I HURTS BERG.
BY HILL I WAS SO.
HI -- TADO.
JACKSON. FOR TITLE II JACKSON I
JONES.
I LIVE A I AM ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL I'M MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NELSON.
I PAN.
HI FORTINO.
BY ROSS.
BY RUBIO.
SKINNER.
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I HAMBURG.
IA CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
I WILL.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS BAIT.
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
MERRELL [inaudible]
RUBIO.
HI IS THIRTY SEVEN OH ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'D LIKE TO
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE
SENATOR STERN ARE YOU PREPARED
YES MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
A SOME A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER --
ONE RELATIVE TO THE SERGEANT
RONALD RON LEE HELLAS MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY.
CENTER STERN.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE -- WITH A SOMBER RESOLUTION --
BUT HOPEFULLY ONE OF SOME HOPE
AS WELL.
WHAT IS THREE POINT FOUR MILES
OF HIGHWAY?
WHEN YOU'RE ZIPPING ALONG
MINDING YOUR OWN BUSINESS IN
YOUR OWN LIFE?
BUT NOW HOPEFULLY WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS RESOLUTION. FOR
THAT LITTLE STRETCH OF TIME
PEOPLE REMEMBER RUN HE WAS.
ON NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND OUR MAN ENTERED THE
BORDERLINE BAR AND GRILL IN
THOUSAND OAKS.
AND MURDERED TWELVE OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIAN COLD COLD BLOOD.
THIS HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
RIGHT BEFORE THE WALLS THE FIRE
IN THE FIRE FRANKLY BURN THROUGH
THIS TRAGEDY IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND FOR MANY IS BEEN FORGOTTEN.
BUT IS NOT FORGOTTEN THOSE OF US
IN VENTURA COUNTY.
WHO KNEW RON?
AND WHAT HE DID AS A SERGEANT --
THAT NIGHT.
HE WAS AMONG THE FIRST OFFICERS
THROUGH THE DOOR THAT EVENING
WHEN MANY WOULD HAVE LEFT A RUN.
HE WENT THROUGH THAT DOOR.
AND HE WAS SHOT SEVERAL TIMES
AND HE'S TRIED TO STOP THE
GUNMAN.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN -- THE FINAL
SELFLESS ACT IN FACT OF A TWENTY
NINE YEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
VETERAN DESCRIBED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES IS NOT JUST HARD
WORKING.
BUT NOW HERE.
HAVE THE HIGHEST DEGREE.
HE WAS SET TO RETIRE IN FACT IN
THE DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE YEAR.
AND WE'LL NEVER KNOW HOW MANY
LIVES HE SAY -- BY HIS
COURAGEOUS CHOICE TO GO TOWARDS
THE FIRE NOT AWAY FROM IT.
BUT WE KNOW.
THAT THAT IMMEASURABLE COURAGE --
SAY MANY.
SO THIS THREE POINT FOUR MILE
STRETCH OF HIGHWAY ALONG THE ONE
OH ONE IN VENTURA COUNTY WILL
NOW BE NAMED BY THIS RESOLUTION
IN HIS HONOR WAS SIGNAGE.
PURCHASED ERECTED ONLY USING ON
STATE FUNDS MIND YOU.
BORN AND RAISED IN CANOGA PARK
THE RUN JOIN THE VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT NINETEEN
NINETY TO PROTECT AND GET BACK
TO HIS COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION TO HIS EIGHT YEARS
OF INTER COUNTY SWAT TEAM THE
ALSO COACH AND MENTOR HUNDRED
THE DEPUTIES.
THROUGH HIS WORK AS A SELF
DEFENSE AND CONCEALED WEAPONS
TRAINING INSTRUCTOR.
SERGEANT HE WAS WAS KIND
[inaudible]
AND COMPASSIONATE [inaudible]
AND CARING.
ANY LOVE DEEPLY AND WAS LOVED
DEEPLY BY HIS WIFE KAREN.
WHO'S BEEN A ROCK IN THIS
COMMUNITY NOT JUST.
FOR THOSE OF US HURTING.
SEARS SELLS GOING THROUGH
TRAGEDY IN THE VICTIM'S PARENTS
LEAN ON HER SHE'S AT EVERY
OCCASION.
SHE IS THERE LIKE A ROCK AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW SHE DOES IT.
BUT HOPEFULLY TODAY KAREN
ANDERSON JORDAN OR WATCHING.
AND KNOW THAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
FOR THEM.
TO AND WE CAN BE THERE ROCK.
TO HE'S WORTHY OF THIS POST YOU
MISS.
DEDICATION AND THE HIGHEST
COMMENDATION FROM THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I WANT TO THANK MY
VERY GOOD COLLEAGUES SOMETHING
OR JACKIE -- WHEN FOR AUTHORING
THIS RESOLUTION FOR BEING THAT
SUPPORT FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN A
TIME OF LOSS AND MORNING STILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE?
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
FIVE EIGHT HI BILL.
I PORGES BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
HI CHAIN [inaudible]
BY DELHI.
I DOT.
I DID ALSO.
I GOT JOHNNY.
I GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROVE.
I HEARD HER.
BY HILL I WAS SO.
I TADO.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES I LIVE A LIME ACQUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
I KNOW SIN IPN.
I PLEDGE TO YOU KNOW.
HI ROSS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AMBERG I HAVE A COPY.
I WINNER.
I WILL BUY HI.
I'D ASK -- FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
THAT OBJECTION.
READ THIS WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES [inaudible]
SENATOR DIED.
I MOVE BUT TO MISTER PRESIDENT.
YES I MOVED TO SUBMIT A LETTER
TO THE JOURNAL AND REFERENCE TO
AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES HI I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
ON THE MOTION THAT WE REQUEST A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
JUST GO.
OKAY MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
NOBEL.
I PORGES BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
I CHAIN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DELHI.
DOT.
BY THE RATHER.
I GOT JOHNNY.
I GLAZER.
BY.
GONZALEZ I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO LLEVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NO SIN.
NO PANTS.
I FORTINO.
HI ROSS BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
BY STONE.
NOVEMBER [inaudible]
OUR COUNTY.
I WINNER BY [inaudible]
WILL [inaudible]
NO NO.
I GOT A WHAT PURPOSE IS YOUR
RIGHT ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS.
ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE
MOTION CARRIES.
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
CENTER WHY CASKEY.
MISTER PRESIDENT BEHALF TO THE
AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO HAVE AB SIXTY
SIXTY FIVE THAT'S FILE NUMBER
TWO FOUR SIX REMOVED FROM THE A
SECOND THEY CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
PURPOSES OF MEN.
THANK YOU SERRA CASKEY DULY
NOTED CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE FILE NUMBER TWO
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX AND OVER WHAT FROM THE
CONSENT COUNTER AT THE REQUEST.
OF A SIMILAR WOOD FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU NOTED AT THE DESK
CENTRE BELL.
MISS PRESENT AS REQUESTED THERE
ARE SR -- WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
A B. OF SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWO SEVEN
ZERO FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OF FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DESK AS NOTED SENATOR DIED.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
MISTER PRESIDENT I'D LIKE -- TO
HAVE AB TEN EIGHTY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLACE ON AN ACTIVE.
AND IN ADDITION I'D LIKE TO AVE --
IT E. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX
ITEM NUMBER -- TWO FORTY REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
PLEASE GIVE US A MOMENT TO
RESTART OF RE SHUFFLE THE DECK
HERE WE'LL GET RIGHT BACK
.
TO ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO PRIVILEGES AT THE FLOOR
SENATOR SCANNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANT TO DO A
INTRODUCTION IN THE GALLERY OF
ZOE MA WHO WILL GRADUATE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO.
M. THIS YEAR -- HER HOMETOWN IS
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA SHE
ATTENDED WOULD CREEK HIGH SCHOOL
AND SHE'S STUDYING MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING.
SHE WILL COMMISSION INTO THE
UNITED STATES NAVY IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND HOPES TO BE
SELECTED AS AN AVIATOR AND FLY
SEARCH AND RESCUE HELICOPTERS.
THIS.
PAST -- COUPLE MONTHS SHE'S BEEN
A QUALITY CALIFORNIA FELLOW IN
MY OFFICE PROVIDING MY
CONSTITUENTS AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS GREAT SERVICE.
AND DID WE VERY MUCH WANT TO
THANK HER FOR HER SERVICE AND
CAN GO AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST WANNA RICE FOR JUST A
MOMENT AND SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
OF OUR STAFF IN THE BACK THAT
JUST WORKS TIRELESSLY AND I KNOW
WE'RE GETTING READY TO LEAVE FOR
THIRTY DAYS IN.
I BET ANYTHING YOU GUYS ARE LIKE
PRAISE GOD RIGHT AND JUST SO
THAT AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR ALL THE LONG HOURS THAT
YOU'VE WORKED I AM ESPECIALLY ON
THIS AT LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES
WHO HAD.
AND THEN I WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE
TO TELL EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TWEETS YOUR
TEXT MESSAGES.
AND THE CARDS THE NOTES
EVERYTHING THAT I GOT FROM
ALMOST ALL OF YOU ON THE FLOOR.
AS SENATE PRO TEM YOU'RE JUST IS
IT IS A SEVEN POINT ONE HIT AND
THIS IS THE FIRST TEXT I GOT YOU
KNOW ARE YOU OKAY.
AND SO AND THEN SHE'S BEEN VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN AND I KNOW THAT --
ALL I I GOT A LOT OF A LOT OF
THINGS A LOT OF NOTES FROM ALL
OF YOU AND I JUST REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT VERY VERY MUCH.
AND WNT TO TELL YOU THAT TO YOU
KNOW SIX POINT NINE AND R. SIX
POINT FOUR AND SEVEN POINT.
ONE AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
LITTLE POOR DESERT AREA.
AND NOT ONE LIKES A LIFE YOU
KNOW NOT WHAT GOD SPARED EVERY
LIFE THERE.
AND THEN -- NOT ONE MAJOR INJURY
WE DO HAVE -- SOME STRUCTURAL
DAMAGE IN THE HOSPITAL AND
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT THE BASE
THAT WE ALL COUNT ON OF TO HELP
OUR WAR FIGHTER IT'S PUBLIC
KNOWLEDGE NOW.
IS A NON MISSION CAPABLE AND
THAT'S PRETTY SCARY THAT -- WE
HAVE A MAJOR FACILITY THAT'S NON
MISSION CAPABLE.
AND CITRINE OUT BUT I JUST
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU GUYS A
REACHING OUT AND AND SAYING
THANK YOU ARE SAYING YOU KNOW
GIVING YOUR WORDS OF SUPPORT --
I'M VERY HAPPY TO REPORT THAT --
WE DO HAVE WATER NOW.
I CAME IN ABOUT THREE FIFTEEN
LAST NIGHT SO MOST ALL OF THEM
HAVE WATER WE SAW THAT 10%
WITHOUT WATER IT'S NOT.
DRINKABLE WATER THEY SELF TO
BOIL IT THERE AND BOILING
RESTRICTION BUT AND THEY'RE A
LOT OF SCARED PEOPLE AND NOW
WHEN I WAS DRIVING THROUGH THE
TOWN THE YESTERDAY WAS THERE.
AND I THINK I DO HAVE TO ROUTE
SIX BLOCKS AND THEN I FINALLY
REALIZE THAT THERE'S TENTS AND
EVERYBODY'S FRONT YARD.
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL SLEEPING
OUTSIDE BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
SCARED TO SLEEP INSIDE.
AND SO -- THAT'S A SCARY FEELING
TO HAVE AND I JUST WANNA THANK
EVERYBODY FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU SENT ME AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROLLED IN.
RIDGECREST CANNOT HAVE A MORE
DEDICATED STATE SENATOR THAN YOU
SO I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN POURING
YOUR HEART AND SOUL INTO THAT
AND HAVEN'T BEEN HERE A LOT THIS
WEEK BECAUSE YOU'RE DOWN THERE
TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS SO.
OUR HEARTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO
YOU AND AND TO YOUR TO THE
PEOPLE.
AT THE RIDGE CREST AREA.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS -- THAT'D BE
FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE SENATOR PAN
ARE YOU PREPARED.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND ARE
GOING TO MEDICARE AND CLEAN
THEIR THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY -- PAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS SP SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR AS
A COMMITTEE BILL THAT'S BACK IN
CONCURRENCE THAT MAKES
CONFORMING CHANGES IN CALIFORNIA
LAW TO REQUIREMENTS AND
STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTRACTS AND
POLICIES.
BUT THE PURPOSE TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW UNDER THE MEDICARE
ACCESS AND CHIP REAUTHORIZATION
ACT.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS MAKE
TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS TO THIS
BILL THESE CHANGES ARE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGED HEALTHCARE AND THE PART
OF INSURANCE CAN CONTINUE TO
OVERSEE THESE PRODUCTS
ESPECIALLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS I BAKES BY BILL
[inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHAIN.
HI DOLLY.
I TAUGHT.
BY THE ROWS OF I GOT JOHNNY.
BY GLAZER BY GONZALEZ.
I GROW.
I HURTS BERG.
BY HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES I LIVE A I'M ACQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK BY AMARILLO.
I KNOW SOME.
I PAN. FIVE FOUR TWO DINO.
BY ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBERG.
IOWA BECAUSE HE I WINNER.
I WILL.
SIZE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
SOME AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
NO WE'RE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN CENTER JONES ARE YOU
PREPARED YES MR PRESIDENT MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ IN ABOUT
THREE THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
JONES AND ACT REALLY INTO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SENATE BILL ENHANCES
CONSUMER PROTECTION BY
CLARIFYING THAT A NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT SIGNED BY A LICENSEE.
MAY NOT PROHIBIT THE LICENSEE
FROM REPORTING NOW PRACTICE TO
THE REGULATORY AGENCY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE BOARD A SYMBOL
AMENDMENTS EXPAND THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO ALL OF THE
INDUSTRIES REGULATED BY THE
BOARD.
LAND SURVEYORS PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS AND GEOLOGISTS PLEASE
VOTE HI.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS I BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHAIN.
I DELI.
I DOT.
HI THERE I WAS A YEAH JOHNNY
[inaudible]
DRUGS WHY.
CAL JOHNNY I GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
I GROW.
I HEARD HER.
I HILL YEAH I DON'T KNOW I WAS
SO.
I TACO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
I LIVE A HI I'M ACQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
I'M ONLY.
BUY MORE LUCK I'M A REAL.
BY NELSON.
BY PM I FORTINO.
BY ROSS.
I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AMBERG.
I WILL CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
I WILL.
HI.
HI IS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEMS SIXTY NINE SENATOR UMBERG.
ARE YOU PREPARED I AM PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT FIVE FORTY FOUR US
SENATOR UMBERG ACKERLEY INTO
ATTORNEYS.
SAID AROUND BERK THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- SP FIVE
FOUR FOUR IS BACK.
ON CONCURRENCE US BE FIVE FOUR
FOUR WILL PROHIBIT THE STATE BAR
FROM REQUIRING APPLICANTS TO
SIGN A MEDICAL WAVERED DURING
THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
WHICH WOULD -- ALLOW ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SIMPLY CLARIFY
OUR INTENT TO ENSURE THAT IF A
PROSPECTIVE APPLICANT WISHES TO
HAVE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS
EXAMINED THEY MAY DO SO ARJUN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
I BAIT.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL.
I CHAIN.
HI DELHI [inaudible]
I DONT.
HI THERE ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER.
BIKE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROVE.
I HURTS.
FOR I HILL I WAS SO.
HI -- TADO.
JACKSON ALLY JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES.
BY LABOR.
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
I'M REAL.
MORALE I KNOW SOON.
I PAN.
I FORTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
TYLER CASKEY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
BY.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES THE CALL.
NOW WE'RE PROCEED TO SEND ITS
THIRD READING FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE SENATOR ALAN.
ALL ITEMS.
SEVENTY MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SEND A CONSTITUTIONAL LIMIT TO
BY SENATOR ALAN AND ACT REALLY
INTO ELECTIONS.
CENTERED AROUND YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS --
AS HE TOO SIMPLIFIES THE RECALL
PROCESS FOR STATE OFFICIALS.
AND ENSURES THAT THE CANDIDATE
WITH THE MOST VOTES WINS THE
SEAT -- COURSES WILL BE PUT TO
THE VOTERS TO DECIDE.
CALIFORNIA'S ONE IN NINETEEN
STATES THAT PERMIT THE RECALL
STATE OFFICIALS THE OTHER STATES
HAVE NO SUCH MECHANISM RELYING
ENTIRELY UPON IMPEACHMENT.
REMOVAL FROM OFFICE OR
REELECTION.
NOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS
WITH A CURT RECALL PROCESS IS
THE VOTER.
CONFUSION THAT IS CREATED BY A
TWO PART QUESTION THIS WRIST
RESULTED IN MANY MANY PEOPLE
VOTING ON THE RECALL QUESTION
BUT NOT ON THE REPLACEMENT
CANDIDATE.
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS ALSO
POSSIBLE FOR THE INCUMBENT TO BE
RECALLED EVEN IF MORE VOTES WERE
CAST. TO KEEP THAT COME N
OFFICE THAT WOULD THEN WORK
CLASS FOR THE REPLACEMENT
CANDIDATES.
SO THIS ADDRESSES THIS
SHORTCOMING CONFUSION IN
CALIFORNIA'S RECALL PROCESS BY
FOLLOWING THE SIMPLER RECALL MET
MODELS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE IN
ARIZONA -- NEVADA NORTH DAKOTA
AND WISCONSIN [inaudible]
HI.
THE THE THE ESEE TO ELIMINATE
THE CONFUSING YES NO RECALL
QUESTION AND INSTEAD PLACE THE
OFFICER BEING RECALLED ON THE
BALLOT WITH THE CANDIDATES
SEEKING. TO REPLACE HIM OR HER
AND AFTER THE VOTES ARE TALLIED
THE CANDIDATE RECEIVING THE MOST
VOTES SHELL THEN WIN THE ELECTED
OFFICE.
I THROUGH THIS TRYING TO RECALL
SINCE SIMPLIFICATION THAT WORKS
VERY WELL THESE OTHER STATES --
THIS WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
CANDIDATE WITH THE MOST VOTES
ACTUALLY WINS THE SEAT.
AND HIS VOTERS A DIRECT CHOICE
ABOUT WHETHER THEY PREFER THE
INCOMING OR DIFFERENT CANDIDATES.
AND I RESPECT FASTER I HAVE A
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS BY BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
NO DOT.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
JOHNNY [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
NO.
GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL [inaudible]
WITH SOME.
WITH A WES I HILL HIGH -- TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR.
I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL BY
MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE.
NO NO SIN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
BY PORCH DINO [inaudible]
HI ROSS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
HI BY STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
IOWA CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILKE.
NO.
SENATOR ALAN MOVES THE CALL.
AND WE ARE GOING TO NOW MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE SENATOR
RUBIO.
PASS ON FILE.
OKAY PASO FILE FILE AND WILL
MOVE THE FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR
SENATOR ALAN.
I PASS ON WHAT.
UPSETS CENTER A WHITE CASKEY.
I'LL FILE NUMBER.
NINETY FIVE NO NO NO NO NO NO.
NICE TRY THOUGH. ONE OF FOUR IS
A PACK.
ALL RIGHT NOW REMOVED TWO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN SENATOR HILL.
AND THIS.
IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THE LEGAL NINE SEVEN THREE BY
SOME IN NUMBER -- WHEN AN
ECHOING HEALING ARTS?
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT -- I RISE 2%.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY THREE WHICH
CLARIFIES THAT COMPLIANCE WITH
THE UNITED STATES FROM WORK
FORMER COPIA NATIONAL FORMULARY.
IS A BASELINE LEVEL OF
COMPLIANCE FOR THE COMPOUNDING
OF DRUG PREPARATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR
DRUG COMPOUNDING ARE CRUCIAL FOR
THE HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC.
SINCE UNSAFE COMPOUNDING
PRACTICES CAN LEAD TO INJURY AND
EVEN DEATH.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
THUS FAR RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU CENTER HILL SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT -- I
STAND IN SUPPORT SOME CAUTIONS --
THE US PHARMACOPEIA IS A A
RESPECTED -- A JOURNAL IF YOU
WILL AND IN THE UNITED STATES
THAT SET STANDARDS.
FOR REALLY MANUFACTURES OF
MEDICATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
AS YOU KNOW WITH THE ADVENT OF A
TECHNOLOGY PHARMACISTS HAVE GONE
BACK TO THE ROOTS OF THEIR
PROFESSION WHEN.
WE USED TO MAKE EVERYTHING FOR A
DOCTOR'S ORDER -- BEFORE THE
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES GREW TO
PROMINENCE AND PHARMACISTS WERE
RELEGATED MORE TO A DISPENSING
ROLE.
IN A CONSULTING ROLE.
RATHER THAN A MAKING ROLE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH.
OVER THE PAST THREE DECADES
[inaudible]
IN PROVIDING.
LIFE SAVING MEDICATIONS.
THAT DO NOT EXIST.
AW IN THE UNITED STATES IN
OFFERED BY COMMERCIAL
PHARMACEUTICALS.
EVERY DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A COMPOUNDING
PHARMACY.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOMETIMES EVENTS THAT HAPPEN AND
IN OUR COUNTRY WHERE.
GOVERNMENT SOMETIMES HAS A KNEE
JERK REACTION AND WANTS.
TO REGULATE TO PREVENT.
RECURRENCES OF OF ISSUES.
THERE WAS A PHARMACY ON THE EAST
COAST CALLED NEW ENGLAND
COMPOUNDING PHARMACY -- MORE
ABOUT SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS AGO.
THAT WAS NOT FOLLOWING THE STATE
BOARD OF PHARMACY ON THE EAST
COAST IN MASSACHUSETTS.
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING COMPOUNDING PHARMACY.
THEY TOOK THEIR EYE OFF THE BALL
AND ALLOW THE COMPANY TO BECOME
MORE OF A CLAUSE I MANUFACTURER.
HAVING A SALES TEAM TRYING TO
SELL THEIR INJECTABLE DRUGS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY WERE NOT OPERATING AS A
TRUE COMPOUNDING PHARMACY.
THE SAD END OF THAT STORY IS
THAT.
MORE THAN FIFTY PEOPLE DIED.
FROM AN INCIDENT.
FROM A BAD BATCH OF AN
INJECTABLE.
THE CAUSE OF FUNGAL MENINGITIS
PROBLEM IN LEFT OVER THREE OR
FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE PERMANENTLY
DISABLED.
THIS IS A HORRIBLE INCIDENT.
AND I HAVE TO SAY SENSE THEM.
STATE BOARDS OF PHARMACY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY [inaudible]
HAVING GAUGED.
LEARN MORE ABOUT WHAT WE DO.
AND HAVE ENACTED GREAT
REGULATIONS.
AND I WANT TO PAY TRIBUTE. TO
OUR STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
PROACTIVE.
AND HAVE PUT FORWARD FORWARD
GREAT GOOD REGULATIONS.
THAT HAVE CLOSED DOWN.
PHARMACISTS THAT HAVE GOTTEN
INTO COMPOUNDING THAT REALLY
DIDN'T HAVE THE EDUCATION. TO
SAFELY DISPENSE AND COMPOUND
MEDICATIONS.
MY FEAR WITH THIS BILL THOUGH IS.
THAT THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY
CAN GO BEYOND.
THE USP STANDARDS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WITH THE
REGULATIONS THAT EXISTS TODAY.
THE COUNT HOW MANY PHARMACIES
ARE ON THE BRINK.
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING [inaudible]
MEDICATIONS.
THE PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES.
IN VARIOUS DISCIPLINES I'LL GIVE
YOU ONE DISCIPLINE AS AN EXAMPLE.
MY COMPOUNDING PHARMACY
SPECIALIZES.
IN PAIN CONTROL.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE.
THAT HAVE SUCH EXTENSIVE PAIN
PROBLEMS [inaudible]
THAT.
THE ONLY MEDICATIONS THAT CAN
HELP THEM.
OUR YES NARCOTIC OPIATES.
ANTI SPASMODIC.
LOCAL ANESTHETICS.
IN SOME CASES GENERAL
ANESTHETICS.
THAT ARE DELIVERED INTO A PUMP.
THAT IS SURGICALLY IMPLANTED IN
THE BODY.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU GET
THE MEDICATION IN THE PALM.
YES SIR A PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE.
BUT THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU CAN
GET THESE MEDICATIONS AND OFTEN
TIMES ARE MORE CONCENTRATED.
THEN EXIST ON THE THE THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET IS THROUGH A
COMPOUNDING PHARMACY THAT HIS
LICENSES ACCOUNT POUNDING
PHARMACY.
AND THEN THEY GET A STERILE
COMPOUNDING LYSONS.
AND HEY AS OPPOSED TO EVERY
OTHER PHARMACY THAT IS
TRADITIONAL GET INSPECTED EVERY
YEAR. TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
COMPLYING WITH THESE VERY
STRENUOUS AND NECESSARY SANDERS.
IF WE MAKE THESE REGULATIONS
[inaudible]
TOUGHER.
IF WE OVER REGULATE.
WE ARE GOING TO CREATE AN ACCESS
PROBLEM. FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT ACTUALLY LIVE A QUALITY OF
LIFE.
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE
RELEGATED. TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT GET THE
MEDICATIONS ON THE
CONCENTRATIONS THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO GO IN THERE PUMPED.
THAT IS THE LIVER TO THEIR
CEREBROSPINAL FLUID THAT HAVE TO
BE MADE WITH NO PRESERVATIVES.
BECAUSE IT'S PRESERVATIVES CAUSE
TREMENDOUS DAMAGE. TO NERVES AND
WE KNOW THAT OUR SPINAL COLUMN
IS JUST LOADED WITH NERVE
NETWORKS.
SO AGAIN I I STAND IN AND
KIRCHER YES VOTE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY THAT -- THEY NEED TO BE
CAREFUL ON GOING BEYOND U. S. P.
STANDARDS IN UNDERSTANDING THE
RAMIFICATIONS TO ACCESS.
BECAUSE WE ARE AT THAT FINE LINE
NOW WERE ANY FURTHER REGULATIONS
BE ON U. S. P..
COULD ACTUALLY SHOT.
EVERY COMPOUNDING PHARMACY TO
THE STERILE WORK IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND HELP.
SOME OF THE MOST PAIN AFFLICTED
PATIENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
THAT HAVE THEIR ADDCTIONS
CONTROL BECAUSE ONLY THE DOCTOR.
CONTROL THIS PUMP THROUGH A
MAGNETIC WAND.
SO IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF YOUR
PATIENTS THAT ARE IN YOUR
DISTRICTS THE GO TO COMPOUNDING
PHARMACIES WE SHOULD SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION BUT WE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE A STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT EXCEEDING THOSE.
REGULATIONS THE CAUSE EXTENSIVE
COSTS IN THE WAY OF TESTING THAT
MIGHT BE REDUNDANT.
THAT WILL MAKE THESE PRODUCTS --
NOT AVAILABLE -- TO THE
PATIENT'S ATTORNEY THEM I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR I VOTE
ON EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY THREE AND
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
SENATOR HILL YOU MAY CLOSE BY
FOR YES RIVAL COLLEGE THANK YOU.
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN.
ARCHULETA.
I HAD GUNS [inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL.
I CHAIN.
IDELI.
I DOT [inaudible]
I DOURADO.
I GOT JOHNNY.
LIKE LASER.
I GONZALEZ.
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
I HER TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
I LIVE IN.
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
I'M MITCHELL [inaudible]
I'M ONLY.
BUY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
HI NELSON.
I PANNED.
BY FORTINO.
HI ROSS.
I REVIEW.
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AMBERG.
IOWA CASKEY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
BY.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS.
ALAN HI HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HI.
THIS.
IS GREAT.
PRICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES SENATOR MITCHELL.
MISTER PRESIDENT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEMS ELEVEN AND TWELVE
PLEASE.
STATE WITHOUT OBJECTION SEEING
NONE.
PLEASE PROCEED ITEM.
ELEVEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
A SOME OF THE ONE TEN BY SOME
REMEMBER TEAM AND A CLAIM TO
STATE BUDGET MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT YOUR BILL.
CENTER MITCHELL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB ONE TEN
IS THE SECOND BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
RELATED TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL AMENDS
THE BUDGET ACT TO PROVIDE UP TO
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEASURES
TO RESPOND TO THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES.
AND TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT ON
VICTIMS RATE PAYERS UTILITIES
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS I ASKED
FOR AND I VOTE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
SAYING NINE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY BATES
[inaudible]
BELL.
BY BURGESS BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
HI DON.
HI THERE ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ I GROVE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL I WAS SO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LLEVA.
I'M CHOIR.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BUY MORE LUCK NO MORALE.
NO [inaudible]
NELSON.
BY PAN.
BY PORCH TINO.
BY ROTH I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE.
NOVEMBER.
PILOT CASKEY I WINNER.
I WILL.
HI. FIVE MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS CHAIN [inaudible]
I TADA. FIVE THIRTY TWO NO SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES MISTER
PRESIDENT I REQUEST IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWELVE AND YOUR READY COURSE SO --
MISTER SECRETARY I MEAN MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
pASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
THAT GOING TO WILD FIRE AGENCIES
AND MAKING PURPOSE THERE FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THE
RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES EIGHTY ONE
ELEVEN IS THE TRAINER BILL --
WHICH CONTINUES OUR WORK WITH
REGARD TO WILD FIRES AND ITS
AFTERMATH THAT ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY AT SPECIFICALLY AB ONE
ELEVEN WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHE RESOURCE
COUNCIL.
THE OVERSEE THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY WITH REGARD
TO WILDFIRE FUND.
SECONDLY THE SABBATH OF THE
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
BY JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
ESTABLISH THE WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION WITHIN THE CPC TO
OVERSEE AND ENFORCE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION'S COMPLIANCE WITH
WILD FIRE SAFETY.
BUDGET BY JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT REQUIRES THAT
THESE FUNCTIONS BE TRANSFERRED
TO THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY.
FINALLY THIS BILL APPROPRIATES
FORTY SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
CPUC UTILITIES REIMBURSEMENT ACT
FUNDS AND TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
FROM THE C. P. U. C. PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE ACCOUNT. TO
THE CPUC THE PHYLLIS DUTIES
PURSUANT TO THIS ACT.
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY ACT WILL
IMPROVE WHILE FIRE SAFETY AND
UTILITY SAFETY STANDARDS BY
CREATING MORE OVERSIGHT.
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE.
THIS ACT ULTIMATELY BENEFITS
ELECTRICAL RATE PAYERS BY
REDUCING CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
CAUSED BY ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS AS WELL AS THE
COSTS AND EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH SUCH DEVASTATION.
I'M ASKING FOR AN I. BOAT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHANG.
BY DOLLY [inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GUESS JOHNNY.
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
I WHISTLE -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LLEVA.
TIME ACQUIRE.
I'M MITCHELL MY MONEY BY MORE
LOCKS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NELSON.
HI PAM.
HI FORTINO.
BY ROTH I REVIEW.
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE.
NOVEMBER.
IRA CASSIE.
I WINNER.
I WILL.
I MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO WAY SO II [inaudible]
MURTADA.
EYES. THIRTY FOUR FOR TITLE II.
RIGHT FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES MISTER
PRESIDENT I REQUEST IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE ASSEMBLY
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO IS THIS A PROPER TIME IF ANY
MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SOMETHING PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AS THE AT THE REQUEST
THE AUTHOR -- PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN
THAT'S A B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE TO THE INACTIVE FILE
[inaudible]
Q.
RIGHT.
GET MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOME OF THE THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
FIVE NINETY NINE OH NINE TEN
NINETEEN SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
SENATE KICKER RESOLUTION FIFTY
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL. 521-535-1640
FOUR SENATE BILL 1-643-343-6640
ONE TO FIFTY ONE FOR EIGHTEEN
ISN'T A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY AS SOME AGO.
1-382-528-0610 EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR THIRTY NINE
S. M. OCCUR RESOLUTION FIFTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX ONE OF THREE A
SYMBOL 498-110-6790 FIVE AND
ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE IS THERE OBJECTION TO USING
AN ANIMUS ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS.
ZERO NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
SPECIAL CONSECUTIVE -- MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ
[inaudible]
BUT PLEASE READ
.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY SIX AND SOME A CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
THIRTY SEVEN OKAY THIS REQUIRES
A ROLL CALL VOTE SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OUR HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I BURGESS BRADFORD.
I COVER YET -- I CHING
[inaudible]
I DELI [inaudible]
I DOT [inaudible]
I'D ALSO.
I GOT JOHNNY.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
I GROW.
I HURTS BERG.
BY HILL.
HI.
WITH SO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES.
I LIVE A I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BUY MORE LOCKED.
I'M REAL.
BY NELSON.
I PANNED BY FORTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AMBERG.
IOWA KELSEY.
I WINNER BY WILKE.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
FORGE BORDERS.
RIGHT FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEASURES PASSES.
NOW WE'RE GONNA BLESS THE CALLS
SO WE'RE A GO BACK.
GO BACK TO SP FIVE FORTY FOUR
FILE ITEM -- SIXTY NINE BURKE
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER.
HI IS THIRTY NINE NO.
ZERO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
NOW WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE S. C. A..
TO MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
THE RISE OF HI [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
ROUGH WELL I SKINNER
[inaudible]
HI.
CAN YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME GORGEOUS.
GROVE [inaudible]
GROVE NO. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NOS.
ELEVEN RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
THANK YOU.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THE
DESK IS CLEAR.
SO THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
[inaudible]
INTERACTIONS YES [inaudible]
DID.
CAN I DID WE HAVE AN INTERNAL
MEMORY.
NO.
OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU.
DID WE HAVE AN INTERNAL MEMORY
OKAY I WILL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE.
THEIR WINNER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES IT IS
WITH -- TREMENDOUS SADNESS THAT
I RISE TO A HOUSE OF THE SENATE
ADJOURNED.
IN MEMORY OF DAVON HAWN.
WHOSE LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT ON MONDAY OF THIS WEEK.
HI HE WAS GUNNED DOWN AT THE
CORNER OF TWENTY FOUR THING CAP
IN SAN FRANCISCO'S MISSION
DISTRICT.
I HE WAS JUST FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
HE JUST FINISHED MIDDLE SCHOOL
AT BESSIE CARMICHAEL.
AND WAS ABOUT TO START HIGH
SCHOOL AT LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL.
FIVE DAY DAY AS HIS CALLED --
HAD A SMILE THAT WOULD LIGHT UP
A ROOM AND A SENSE OF HUMOR TO
MATCH -- THOUGH HE WAS SOFT
SPOKEN HE WAS KNOWN TO BE MATURE
BEYOND HIS AGE.
HE WAS CONSIDERED A VOICE OF
REASON AND WISDOM.
AMONG HIS PEERS AND HIS FRIENDS.
A NATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
MISSION DISTRICT.
I HE WAS AN ACTIVE AN INTEGRAL
MEMBER OF HIS COMMUNITY -- HE
WAS VERY INVOLVED IN WAS A
FIXTURE AT AN ORGANIZATION IN MY
DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO CALLED
UNITED PLAYERS.
WHICH IS A VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION.
THAT BOTH WORKS WITH -- PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED TO
HELP GET THEM RE INTEGRATED.
AND ALSO BRINGS IN YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY STAY SAFE AND DO
NOT.
GET INTO THE SYSTEM THAT HELPS
KEEP OUR YOUTH SAFE.
AND HE WAS VERY VERY INVOLVED IN
UNITED PLAYERS.
AS A PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT UNITED
PLAYERS CRYSTAL MORALES SAID.
QUOTE HE WAS ON THE ROAD MAP OF
A RISING YOUNG STAR.
WHO WAS WELL MANNERED WITH POISE
AND INTELLECTS?
COLLEAGUES WE MUST DO MORE TO
END THE PLAGUE OF GUN VIOLENCE
THAT IS TAKING OUR CHILDREN.
AWAY FROM US THE IDEA THAT I
WOULD HAVE TO STAND HERE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE.
AND TALK ABOUT AND YET ANOTHER
[inaudible]
CHILD'S.
WHO WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED WITH A
GUN?
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WHICH I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO --
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR
SOCIETY SHOULD NOT TOLERATE AND
YET WE DO TOLERATE.
ED BY ALLOWING THIS VIOLENCE AND
THIS GUN CULTURE TO CONTINUE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
WE OWE IT TO DAY DAY INTO
EVERYONE WE'VE LOST -- TO PUT AN
END TO THIS VIOLENCE SO THAT OUR
CHILDREN.
CAN FEEL SAFE IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND GROW TO BECOME
THE LEADER IS THAT THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF BEING.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING
TODAY IN MEMORY OF DAVE ON HAN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE KNOW THAT
IT.
IS TRAGIC AND THANK YOU FOR
HONORING HIS MEMORY.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
THE YOUNG CENTER ACTIONS THE
DESK IS CLEAR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU.
FEEL THAT WE'VE HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVE COUPLE OF WEEKS.
BY IN A NUMBER OF AREAS AND SO
ON BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS I
WANT TO THANK YOU.
AND NOW YOU'RE ABLE TO GO HOME
TO YOUR COMMUNITIES YOUR
CONSTITUENTS YOUR FAMILIES --
AND SPENT A GOOD COUPLE OF WEEKS
THERE -- PAID ATTENTION -- TO TO
ALL THAT'S IMPORTANT HOME. TO
OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER WE WISH
YOU ALL THE BEST IS TRONA AND
RIDGE CREST IN THE COMMUNITIES
THERE.
I CONTINUE TO HEAL WE HOPE AS WE
VOTED THIS WEEK FOR CLEAN WATER
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE SURE
HOPE THAT WATER GETS RESTORED IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
BUT OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH YOU AND AND THE FOLKS OUT
THERE SO WITH THAT.
GO HOME ENJOY YOUR TIME AWAY AND
WE WILL SEE YOU BACK HERE IN
AUGUST.
MONDAY AUGUST TWELFTH AT TWO PM.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE'LL
RECONVENE MONDAY AUGUST TWELFTH
TWO PM.
MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT SUMMER